[Music]
well so far this year there have been
more than 2 500 cases of covid within
the clark county school district so as
kids march back into the classroom
families need to make sure that they're
getting enough rest build their immunity
and they're simply eating right we'll
actually help them have a strong
foundation for fighting the virus or
really even the common cold now i spoke
with dr nicole avena who's a nutrition
specialist and a mother who takes a
holistic approach to children's health
now diet is key right fruits and
vegetables are a no-brainer so when
you're packing their lunch or their
after-school snack make it a healthy
choice some of those crispy fruit
packets or veggies and dip especially in
a pandemic we're doing our kids a
disservice by not putting them on the
right track to eating healthy at a young
age
children who learn these poor eating
behaviors and poor strategies around
food early in life tend to take those
with them as they get older and that can
lead to poor eating habits later on that
can lead to obesity lead to increased
risk for heart disease cancers diabetes
and also complications from getting
things like covid
so if you think your child might be
coming down with something make sure
they're getting sleep they're staying
hydrated and then something over the
counter like zycam can do a lot to
shorten their illness dr evina also
recommends a good multivitamin to make
sure kids are getting enough vitamin d
which has been proven to help immunity
really at any age